this one's going to sting for some of
you but in every company specifically
today during strange times
there's going to be bad citizens there's
going to be reliable citizens and
there's going to be impactful citizens
the great companies that go through
challenging times recession market crash
whatever you want to call it and they
don't just survive but they Thrive they
know how to differentiate between these
three and they know how to take reliable
citizens and help them become impactful
citizens AKA leaders we're going to talk
about that today so stick around to
levarian I'm going to give you a PDF of
today's message this is something having
to do with you as a leader you you're
going to receive this message and say
Pat how can I become a better leader
during this time or you as a leader of
other people you're going to say how can
I help identify who's a bad citizen
who's a reliable Citizen and who's an
impactful citizen that can make better
leaders in my organization so let's get
right into it
foreign
reliable citizen impactful reliable
citizen the company grows steadily the
community grows steadily impactful the
company the community the society
explodes because they create better jobs
to make people better they make
organizations Better anything any word
they're part of impactful citizens they
make it better no matter where you put
them right so let's talk about bad
Citizens First a bad citizen in any
organization company Community they
divide they sabotage they know it all
you can't teach them anything they talk
behind people's back they don't want to
learn more there's no way you can get
this person to address conflict
sometimes they want to fight the
conflict it's everybody else's fault
nothing is their fault they blame
everyone I don't need to explain to you
what a bad citizen is is always late
there's a reason for being late people
have it out for them you know the boss
doesn't like them the boss doesn't have
them as a favorite no matter what you do
you can't do nothing right in the eyes
of a bad citizen sometimes what leaders
make a mistake of is thinking they can
change them they can't change a bad
citizen only a bad City citizen can
change themselves nobody else one of the
most powerful affirmations I ever told
myself 17 years ago 16 years ago that
got me to be a little bit of a better
leader is I said stop trying to be God
that job is already taken you can't
change people people have to choose to
change on their own and I spend a lot of
time trying to change bad citizens I've
failed 100 of the time so now let's talk
about the difference between being a
good citizen a reliable Citizen and
being a impactful citizen good citizen
there's two things we got to look at one
is their character a reliable citizen
has a very good character what does this
mean today sponsors Masterworks matter
of fact I really like what Masterworks
does because a lot of people can't
afford to buy a whole art piece for two
million dollars what Masterworks does is
they buy the art piece they file it with
the SEC then members are able to buy and
sell shares that's what they do now keep
in mind you know this is like you can't
buy all of Apple for two and a half
trillion dollars but you can buy an
Apple stock for a few hundred dollars
similar story one thing you need to know
about how much wealth is being held in
art today is an estimated 1.7 trillion
dollars millionaires billionaires have
held their wealth and art Deloitte says
it's going to increase another 900
billion dollars by 2026 what Masterworks
does is the last five paintings they
sold since 2017 their average rate of
return was 26.8 percent and Contemporary
Art prices have outperformed S P 500
Total return ready by 164 percent the
past 26 years so if this is something
you want to take advantage of we're
going to put the link below there is a
waiting list for people that are trying
to get into this program with
Masterworks but because you're part of
valuetainment if you click on the link
below and you go through value to me you
will skip the waiting list and you'll be
able to start buying and selling shares
immediately they show up on time they
get the job done if they tell you
they're going to do it they do it they
don't steal they don't cheat they take
responsibility they're respectful their
unifiers they're willing to give ideas
to they're willing to be taught they're
willing to be challenged they're willing
and to improve they're a willing
personality they're able to reason they
are somebody that if you go out and talk
to them you you like being around them
you like their company they're reliable
right they're reliable and their
character is strong it's very very
important they have a very good
character but character alone doesn't
take you all the way to the top that's
just the foundation on the other side
for somebody that's reliable but maybe
wants to get compensated more in the
market pays more for them is when
somebody has great character and they
also have a hard skill what's a hard
skill I know how to edit I know how to
code I know how to do customer service I
know how to process a policy anything
that's a hard skill they know how to do
okay so it's a hard skill and character
you have a reliable citizen here hard
skill is a skill set and character is a
foundation of who the person is the
Market's going to pay very good for this
person but not at the highest level the
impactful citizen they have two things
that these folks at the bottom don't
have the impactful citizen has the
character has the heart skills but they
have two additional things let me tell
you what these two additional things are
they have soft skills those who are
impactful citizens have soft skills
meaning they know how to deal with
different personalities they know how to
communicate with somebody that's white
somebody that's black somebody that's
married somebody that's single somebody
that's widowed somebody that's divorced
somebody with a degree somebody with no
degree a person that's very rich a
person that's in a middle a person
that's very poor person that's a
customer partner an employee and
executive it doesn't matter they have
soft skills they know how to overcome a
challenge there's people that are losing
their cool around them they know how to
bring everybody and say guys let's try
to figure this out they know how to
address conflicts they know how to
overcome conflicts they know how to have
crucial conversations without offending
without being a jerk without being an
[ __ ] they know how to do that it's
the EQ it's the soft skills they know
how to deal with people and somehow some
way people that continuously move up in
any company in any society and in any
Community they tend to have very very
good soft skills this applies to church
to politics to business to sports to
anything you look at soft skills you
generally see people at the top that are
leaders they're very very good soft
skills so you may be watching the same
path can I really improve my soft skills
absolutely you can improve your soft
skills you can learn how to communicate
better you can learn by taking courses
on how to be better at addressing
conflicts deal with different
personalities take body language courses
you can take a bunch of different things
to improve in this area but if you do
want to move up and have a leadership
position where you're becoming an
impactful citizen you've got to have
soft skills so now so far we have a lot
we have character we have hard skills we
have soft skills the market pays a very
very well for a person that has these
three areas and then we have the last
one and the last one may be the biggest
one and my job as a father as a leader
as a man leading organizations your job
for yourself and your job as a leader
both so I got to figure out a way to
constantly improve myself and I gotta
figure out a way to help people around
me improve themselves as well number
four is by far the best one out of all
of them and this one takes a regular
person into a completely different level
and that is putting people in situations
to have a paradigm shift now what are we
talking about with Paradigm Shift let me
explain to you paradigm shift to me is
for many many years this man named June
used to take his leaders he worked with
to La at uh skid row on Christmas
morning and I said do you mind if I
Johnny and I started joining him there
was a story behind the story with his
daughter I don't need to get into that
but I was inspired so every Christmas
morning the 25th people would come to
the office we did this 10 years straight
they would come to the office at 4 30 we
would go by Big Mac cheeseburger
toothpaste toothbrush blanket and we
would go to Downtown LA and we would
give these things away to folks first
time we went we went with 10 people then
20 then 30 then 40. then I think the
last year we did it we went with nearly
200 people that we went there to help
these folks out now why was this a
paradigm shift parents started bringing
their kids because say somebody's making
a lot of money but they don't know what
it is to be homeless they would bring
their kids and it's early in the morning
one time a guy pulled out a knife this
big of a knife on another homeless
person because they said that's my
blanket you can't take it and they're
fighting and I said guys we don't need
to fight let us go get another blanket
for you when you see that right there as
a kid you're gonna have a paradigm shift
you sit there and say oh my God imagine
to drive back with that son and the
daughter talking to the mom and dad
saying mom is that really how some
people live that's what happens some
people live how did these people become
homeless
some of it has to do with bad decisions
some of it has to do with drugs some of
it has to do with alcohol some of it has
to do with economy some of it has to do
with bad associations if you make bad
decisions this can happen to anybody but
regardless of it we have to figure out a
way to choose to contribute to society
and help these people out so then they
sit there and they say oh my God that's
unbelievable and they're thinking about
that the entire time I had a one time a
couple of my guys who were Guatemalan
and you know the idea was we want to
kind of you know Paradigm Shift we have
a paradigm show for a couple of our
leaders one guy on December 26th of 2004
we got on a plane we went to Guatemala I
went to Puerto Barrios Livingstone Tikal
Tikal all the grand Jaguar we went to
all these places and we went to a church
I spoke to a church most Guatemalans are
not very tall 410 5 feet tall and I have
a picture with me around them talking to
a church of 500 people and I'm speaking
English and they don't speak English and
I have a translator with me and then we
went to another church that fits 15 000
members that just opened up I think John
Maxwell was the opening one this place
had all these different uh volcanoes
water volcanoes that's a paradigm shift
for the people that went there Paradigm
Shift could be Remember the Titans when
Denzel Washington says whites in this
bus and blacks on this bus no get out
defense offense get on the buses take
some to a cemetery takes them to a place
where War happened he says when a war
happens nobody cares if you're white or
black everyone's your brother you get
their back they get your back strong
side weak side left side right side no
one cares we got to have each other's
back what he's doing that coach that
they made a movie about and Denzel
starred in it that coach is creating a
paradigm shift for the players to no
longer see colors it's called a paradigm
shift you need to go to events to have a
paradigm shift I went to a Billy Graham
event in 2003 November of 2003 it was in
Pasadena at the Rose Bowl I went four
days every day I went to it and I
watched this I went with as many people
I could take myself as an atheist I went
I had paradigm shift I can tell you
hundreds of stories of me having a
paradigm shift every time I want to
recreate myself to go to the next level
I have to put myself in situations to
have a paradigm shift if I want my
organization to have a paradigm shift I
got to create that climate for them to
go see things they've never seen before
if we're watching Men in the arena with
Tom Brady I rent out the Foxborough
stadium and we sit there and we watched
a documentary of 10 episodes together
and we bring out three different New
England Patriots that played with Brady
and Belichick and they give the
perspective of man in the arena from the
player's standpoint that's a paradigm
shift so now let me go back to it again
bad citizens you're not God you can make
miracles happen they have to choose to
change
if you're watching this you know if
you're a bad citizen because you
probably are not watching this video
anymore very few bad citizens will watch
this video through they're going to stop
it after the first 30 seconds but if
you're still watching it you want to
change
I applaud you know who you are you got
to make some changes because if you're a
bad citizen I hate to say to you life
sucks and you know it and if you keep
going like this it's gonna suck even
more if you're a reliable citizen you've
got a strong character you know it you
got a heart skill you know it but if you
want to be an impactful citizen you got
to start taking some courses to have
better soft skills you got to go out
there and put yourself in situations to
have a paradigm shift to start realizing
you can make a bigger contribution to
the world to the company you're a part
of to the city to the country to your
ethnicity to whatever it is you need
that paradigm shift so now
this is a message given to you to those
who want to become impactful citizens if
that's you you can get this PDF
subscribe to the newsletter below we'll
send this to you and I give a talk last
week I think in Long Beach
uh at the driven event where I talk
about this as a keynote for about an
hour if you've never watched it it's
very direct it's very very it's tough to
watch because I'm going to be very
direct with you for an hour but if you
have the tolerance to watch somebody
being very direct with you for an hour
highly recommend you click over here to
watch the keynote having said that take
care everybody bye-bye
foreign
[Music]